are we live
I think we're live you're live says the
machine can you hear us you know the way
this goes jump on it let us and you hear
us we'll be in stereo it will behoove
you to listen with both ears if you've
got a choice what's up people are we in
focus yeah you they can hear us
Thank You Cedric shouts out to Cedric
for being the first person to tell us
today
so hey what's up TM Rizzo gaming Ryan
Beatty creative gaming always happened
to be here on a Saturday evening with
all you guys
I feel like Saturday just our best day
ooh Oh Joel I like your pic I have a
list right here of my movies that I want
to I want to read off that's right
John's got a deku sure John would you
get that deck once you get that my hero
academia shirt John I think I got it
yesterday sometime maybe for a special
occasion and maybe my my dearest friend
of the most years I've known anybody
could have given it to me it's very
possible I'm assuming you're talking
about me I
let's make John's birthday about Greg
great riggidy riggityrekt you know
shot-glass
so the only thing that you could have
done better in this moment is get us
some of those orange juice whiskey shots
the vodka shots sorry yeah I know shots
today
no alcohol now you're Aaron Cedric
awesome to take a break you've been
hitting it too hard lately gee how did
you turn yesterday Jesse yesterday okay
here here's my way if you're new here
you probably are because of the fact
that we just started the stream can you
hit that like button
more people will notice the stream if
there's a like button there
happy birthday Joey do you remember
saying happy birthday to you no cuz it's
a copyrighted song oh [ __ ] that is vide
happy birthday to you happy birthday to
you
John's birthday mr. jumping in happy
birthday did John happy birthday to you
happy birthday to everybody else whose
birthday is on June the 12th and and
June see oh okay I should Clara and in
mentioned to you guys right up front
he's halfway to Christmas Eve you I told
everyone
that's a patriot about this
so okay on Thursday when the PlayStation
event was happening we were trying to
get a head on like certain YouTube and
patreon videos in advance and then all
that PlayStation stuff started coming
out and we just failed to notice it and
sort of like aw crap forgot readjust
everything so and because we had Schmoe
down matches to record yesterday and
then it was John's birthday yesterday so
I was like it'd be great if he just like
Diedre short a match and you didn't have
to come in that week his hat like just
relax then he ended up having to come in
after 5:00 p.m. yesterday and then we
shot a reaction for Supernatural we're
trying to just make sure we're on
schedule for the patreon to do's and
then I was like what do you want for
dinner man and then he's gone burger
king so he went to Burger King got food
and somehow I'm the only one of the
three who got like serious food
poisoning last night I had no there's no
meat in there I got it's like insane
food poisoning last night so I was like
we were watching a Miyazaki movie first
studio he's delivery service sad part is
first time I've ever watched a Studio
Ghibli movie and then I just like
towards the end I had to keep I left the
room I just started vomiting and then
this went out to like 5 o'clock in the
morning I just couldn't stop vomiting
and got about 3 hours of sleep so I'm
gonna be a little bit chiller today turn
on some reggae in the background or dig
in take it easy and we're just gonna
celebrate movie theater I thought this
would be a fun theme to do today hey
because it's an easy want to talk about
or I'm already seeing a lot of great
pics in here from you guys in the chat
the other thing is is like with it and
since Jon didn't really get a sub for
his birthday and since I'm ending this
video with him I was like well the main
thing we did together
go to the theaters all the time so and
that's what a lot of us are here for too
right
so yeah I thought this would be a really
fun one to do and then I see a lot of
you guys already sending some super
chats and we're gonna definitely be
doing that you can look at the super lat
you can go to Stream labs as well but
yeah John with you being your birthday
let's kick it off buddy what's the first
what's one of your favorite movie
theater going experiences actually one
of my very favorites of all time was I
got to go on my 20th birthday it was
like the midnight of it was like I was
in line for this movie on June 11th and
by midnight you know I was watching it
and it's my very favorite movie wait is
there something up with our audio we're
hearing people seeing people a couple
people in the chat saying uh to my I
mean I haven't tweaked any settings in a
new way but like I said yeah if you have
a two headphones set up one of us will
be in the left side one of us will go
really the right side yeah okay so it's
actually good I tried it is at the top
and you know if you're just joining and
obviously you didn't hear but yeah if if
it's a big hindrance I can find a way to
make this all mono because right now
we're just feeding in through a two
channel interface okay but yeah if you
have the option of two left right you
know both nerimon I misunderstood all
right go ahead John what was the movie
you were gonna say sorry for cutting I
went to I believe it was the new art
theater I want to say it was probably
was either that yeah I think it was the
new art or the new bed one of the two
and I got to see my very favorite movie
at the stroke of midnight on my 20th
birthday which is Ed Wood
no nice revival screening I believe it
was like an actual film print nice and
and it was like falling in love with
that movie all over again cuz it was the
first time I'd ever saw it on the big
screen and you know it wasn't like the
hugest crowd but um and I think even our
buddy Aaron like I I was just going on
my own and then he did that thing that
he does which is very charming which is
he'll just be like he'll hit you up and
just be like what are you up to and I
was like I'm doing this he's like mind
if I come on I was like you know I'm
like let's let's freakin do it and it
was lovely and beautiful and and you
I know it's a story with your birthday
involved but I don't want to hear about
your other best friend okay all right
let's not do that today John I don't
know include a story that includes me
huh god I'm sorry I mean I'm being
self-absorbed I'm sorry hey man
one of my very favorite one of the most
memorable movie-going experiences I've
ever had I mean it's the thing is I have
several memories of this specific movie
with you but the first one I mean it it
has to be the day I I camped out for
like 10 12 hours holding us spots in
line for the Dark Knight we eventually
shared a lot of our shirt a good like
eight of those nine of those hours
whatever man is doesn't compare to what
my brother did my Matrix Reloaded
this isn't your brother's birthday my
brother pulled me out of school I know
it's cooler for Matrix Reloaded all to
wait in line because this is before they
had reserved seating like anywhere and
he hadn't Jabby Cohen I'm talking about
him all right
he pulls ona he pulled me out of school
to go wait in line for Matrix Reloaded
now when I say he pulled me out to wait
in line I mean he pulled me out so I
could be a singular entity to wait in
line by myself and he showed up like an
hour before I waited in line for about
ten hours by myself and he shows up with
like eight other people so this is not
one of my favorite yeah put you in an 8
he took advantage Smith oh damn we got
Biff in the chat who saw freaking The
Crow oh wow he's great
the Dark Knight yeah that was that was a
[ __ ] and experience and I mean we we
went several other times after that but
that was the time they ran the high
school music trailer just no high school
musical 3 or 3 yeah high school musical
trailer and man I'll kick this off with
an obvious one and mine the first
Avengers movie was amazing you know it's
funny about this about with this the
today favorite theater-going experiences
I can say all the Avengers movies except
for age of Ultron but all the other
Avengers the ones with Avengers in the
title were completely memorable
experiences age of Ultron was look
alright but Avengers 1 was magic and
infinity war was surprising an end game
was this might be my favorite MCU movie
so yeah like those easily experiences
but I got some pics here that you guys
might not expect they're not all gonna
be comic-book movies and by experience
it could just be something we know
simple but alright so John you won't
pull up those uh how do you pull this up
do that do that thing you do John John's
more the techy guy on this side of
things
super chadway the ones with the super
Jets will be honored yeah today but who
else are a team America team America
World Police I'm seeing in the chat chat
I you knew you weren't with us did you
know I saw that later in life on video
damn dude
yeah we went I stuck into that with
David Henry from was early place and our
friend Brandon Melgar and we were dying
if we were at eighth grade and we were
dying laughter your mom pie didn't let
you come you watching Debra haha I'm
still mad at you for not letting John
come with us eighth grade party horse
you got him here I did John why would
you not be invited I don't know I don't
remember not being able to go see Team
America at some point so yeah I've just
blocked it from my brains but anyway
yeah I mean guys what are some like with
some child while we're gonna go through
some of these super tests and we'll go
back we're gonna hop around but how we
do our streams as we hop around between
just the live stream chat the super
chats and then our own takes as well so
where are we at here thanks to Jurassic
room
thanks solving for most thanks to all
the people who have been contributing in
the stream labs one as well it takes
that's less percentage that YouTube just
pockets so appreciate that you guys but
what are we out here first one on the
list once upon a time and Carter Lovejoy
Carter Lovejoy is so consistent with
super chatty
before we've ever even before we even
goal I appreciate that dude he says once
upon a time in Hollywood Sun and
35-millimeter last year were my dad and
it was chefs kiss mwah
perfect I love my experience and once
upon a time in Hollywood because it's
one of my go-to stories to establish how
badass my girlfriend is and I'm gonna
repeat this story in case you guys
haven't heard it yet and this is with it
was Once Upon a Time in Hollywood right
so for those who have seen the movie
this is not a big spoiler there's a
scene where DiCaprio he's like a
struggling actor and he really wants to
make sure that he's like he has this big
scene where his big monologue and he and
he starts killing it right it's this big
moment for him in the in the film and
someone's phone just started going off
and then they took the call and they
were just talking like about as loud as
I'm talking right now it says if the
movie was too loud for her phone call
conversation and and everyone is just
looking around but no one's saying
anything and then Olivia who's obviously
right usually when the three of us go to
the theaters Olivia sits in between us
and she sees that this person is like at
least eight to ten rows away somewhere
there and she gets up from the seat
walks out and goes you need to get off
your phone or take your call
outside right now you're being rude and
she walks back up and for me John
included we'd probably wait for like a
half hour really contemplate how we're
gonna approach the situation she's like
what the [ __ ] going on we're watching
a movie no one said anything near her so
she had to go down walk down some steps
just to tell this person to get off
their [ __ ] yeah that was a great one
John what's the next one here super
chats gene Jeter TV wishing you a John
filled with happiness and a John filled
with joy happy birthday John Thank You
gene thank you much
thank you for brightening up my my day
follow Gene Jeter on YouTube people go
down a gene Jeter shaped rabbit hole you
will not
Oh what else is going on here in the
chat last movie as Mansoul scourge a you
haven't seen a movie since Rocket Man
you're late in the game buddy dude
that's a great movie to have left off on
though I love them there's a lot what's
great about this question I think that's
awesome like a favorite movie going
experiences is that they're so this
could be like very recent movies not
this year but very recent movies you
know like movies from your childhood as
well so I mean for us I'm pulling a
little bit more from the younger years
here but who's next on here Rizzo gaming
Ryan he's saying endgame
thanks Ryan Beatty endgame UK cinemas
are usually quiet but the place erupted
during the midnight screening Jurassic
world and force awakens and 1917 dude no
one I don't the last thing I expected on
this answer list was [ __ ] Jurassic
world that's fun of a movie going
experience as that is it was not exactly
anyone Alistair aslak world force
awakens yeah that seemed like an obvious
one nineteen seventeen that was pretty I
saw that cuz of you I mean I wanted to
see it haha but he sought twice before I
ever saw it or not a Nogami jealous so I
went I mainly went because I couldn't
let John jealousy okay yeah I was very
jealous I'm glad I was able to inspire
that emotion and you see a terrific
motion picture oh goodness gracious we
got even people over on the stream libs
yeah man did you guys watch Artemis I
haven't seen orders fell yet no I'm
gonna watch it to five Bloods and then
I'll watch Artemis how did you turn
yesterday John 19 19 years old John is
you look terrible for your age oh my god
John you look awful god-awful I'm old
enough now to party yeah actually Civil
War going off of Kyle in the Civil War
was pretty [ __ ] excited especially
when Spiderman came on actually it
wasn't when Spiderman came on-screen it
was when
Piderman came on it was when uh the code
the word queens popped up and everyone
was like yeah that's all it took for the
crowd to get excited that night back now
and I don't think I saw civil war than
he did not I showed it to you at home
yeah that's a crazy thing that now I'm
thinking back why didn't I see that in
the theaters with Iowa I'm walking away
you weren't as involved in the channel
yet so we weren't necessary to be in the
we did all the reviews for the most part
except the ones you did by yourself as
straight to the point with Ryan Ryan
know there was some there was some II
didn't wonder Lana you can catch all the
Marvel ones with me I think I did it
with Andrew Gordon I'll make a yeah
let's see here RZA Nate John take that
one Wheaton and Nancy happy birthday
John celebrating mine on Monday nice to
be an auspicious company Gemini season
is afoot yeah what is a Gemini
personality consists of haha um well
Gemini's and air signs so you know you
associate us with being free-spirited
maybe a bit flighty I don't know people
can probably tell you people usually
roll my roll their eyes at me when I say
Gemini so I don't know I guess very
mercurial but understanding good
mediators but you know prone to being a
lot of different people there are people
who can easy you guys sound great yeah
people don't usually respond well when I
say that the most common trait is we
don't know anything about ourselves I am
NOT the greatest expert to just sum it
up in a nutshell for you just be like
hear it but yeah I don't know where
we're airy we're a little
I don't know I could for whatever reason
I'm having a hard time articulating it
right now because I'm mostly hearing the
cynical self conscious thought in my ear
all right
let's let's see here agoura foegoer
phobic factory fanboy I can't read from
this far a agoraphobic fanboy kill but
this is this is one of the movies on my
list right here on this yellow legal
notepad you got it right here dude
oh yes right I'll [ __ ] love this
guy's profile face profile face I love
your profile vase kill boy kill boy kill
boy threw up all night last night sorry
I'm still getting some fluid in my brain
so I'm drinking this water Kill Bill Vol
1 when I saw that anime tickets for the
first time things got real Tarantino was
way ahead of his film film changed me to
Kill Bill Vol 1 when I saw it in the
theaters I went my convinced my dad to
take me it was the first Center to know
movie I've ever seen
went opening night Friday night and that
we couldn't sit next to each other like
I said no reserved seedings at this time
in our lives and I sat by myself I was
like 12 or 13 something like that when
Kill Bill came out first Tarantino movie
I ever saw and honestly for some reason
at that age the movie was actually kind
of scary like nowadays I don't think
it's scary at all there's like tension
and stuff but back then when I was a
little kid and having no idea what to
expect the tenseness of that whole movie
just had me like scared the entire time
but I was also so wrapped up and so
enamoured in it Kill Bill Vol 1 easily
one of my favorite theater going
experiences I'm really happy you said
that a agoraphobic fanboy really happy
you put that on there dude
alright now for those of you wondering
Gemini's are adaptable easygoing and
adjustable outgoing intelligent choice
is impulsive unreliable and nosy oh my
John that is you
not nosy but the rest of them oh my god
John you were there yeah congratulations
Jules you cried you see that's why
people subscribe and and you know I get
mercury as my planet who's always
destroying things and is the god of
communications which obviously I'm
trying not to turn celebrating your
birthday into a roast session let me
find a not gonna do it today if anybody
knows me they know I'm not great at
telling people how to celebrate my
birthday so you know you could do it -
I've this guy's never ever ever just
held a birthday thing for himself I
don't know 30 years old and never
celebrate it never I've no time been to
a birthday celebration for July go home
where there's like actual people someone
else put it together for him as a
surprise that's about it he's napped for
some reason he's only I don't know why
you don't ever try anything there are a
lot of reasons I guess it's it's but but
they boiled down to just for whatever
reason that's one of those things that's
natural to a lot of people that I didn't
get the starter pack for way back when
that's too bad so all right let's do one
more here and then we're gonna just hop
around some of our own personal picks
but we'll come back to these John take
it away to Nyssa the girl you're gonna
bang at the gas station go for a vengers
in game is one of my favorite ones being
in that theater with everyone like that
was a moment that will be there forever
also when I screamed my head off with
cap getting the hammer oh great great
moment man can Barry rule imagine being
in the theater with Anissa screaming
leaving you a hand job if it's an essay
she's gonna be giving issue yeah you get
annoyed
I was gonna make a joke reference to
theater-going experiences but that I
decided to not do that no smart watch
yourself well mystery never heard
anybody know yeah I mean I've been in
theaters with other screaming people so
I can imagine Anissa screaming I've
heard a nice voice I can extrapolate
alright I'm not gonna get lascivious
with this fancy oh boy where did we
leave off an angel got its wings just
then all right so let's well thank you a
nice I appreciate that dear and yeah end
game I feel like end games are all gonna
be the way the most talked about one
here is someone I'm called out Hobson
Shaw Hobson Shaw who wear my best cinema
experience Cooper hoody okay yeah well
anyway yeah hilarious and unrealistic
but everyone loved it I mean I'm happy
for you yeah I'm seeing someone in the
chat who keeps bringing up a star is
born and that was my favorite movie that
you're so easily my favorite movie going
experience of the year it came out I
wasn't expecting to cry so much and be
swept up in so much emotions throughout
the another one that I would personally
pick is I'm doing this for John's
birthday John is spent you know I'm the
one who's sick and John's the one who's
especially reserved right now why are
you so chill right now John I'm sorry
you know what I was planning on for this
stream was John would be the energy you
know it's not it's not your birthday I
don't know where things are gonna come
from but they're all about me and that
makes me self-conscious well I was gonna
say one here that my girlfriend has for
no reason has no interest in watching
but I would say it's one of the best
movie theater going experiences we've
had together it is the movie I love you
where they gave us pirouettes at the
street and free popcorn we saw I Love
You Man a year nuts in LA especially the
parts of the world they do it to where
they have like usually these guys are
hanging out at movie theaters and they
hand out these pamphlets of like you
want to go out to free movie you are
free movie huh it's just stars Paul J
Suzuki wants you [ __ ] and then you go
watch the movie get free bags and they
are there they're pretty aggressive
about it you know
anyhow we went to go watch it not know
anything about it and yeah I remember I
had like a really gnarly headache watch
before the film started and I was just
laughing so much that my head hurt yet I
felt so good because that was such a to
me that's like one of my favorite
comedies of all time it's like a lot of
people still haven't seen that movie you
haven't seen the movie I Love You Man go
check it out that is one of my okay
for those who don't care Scott laying a
man all right go watch yeah and
eventually Jason Segel again the emcee -
there's a couple Kyle seeing it in the
chat I'm seeing that right now I love
that movie yeah that's one of those
movies it's like one of our yes and to
reference a different movie under
similar circumstances I always think
back to that time when we got to see the
one of the early cuts of funny people
because that movie turned out like
decent but like that one cut that we saw
was like such a beautifully composed
movie that I'd never it like that was a
very special experience too because it's
weird to see something change so much
and realize I literally only got the
experience that one time and I can't get
it again yeah yeah I always think back
on that one it's like a a precious
little what could have been we saw yeah
he's he's talking about we saw an early
cut of the movie funny people and it was
very different than the one that's out
cuz a lot more it was a lot more it was
a lot less blunt well you know how Judd
Apatow likes to let his actors improvise
so he has a bunch of different he
literally can make a very very different
feeling a movie based off the amount of
different kinds of takes he has per
scene Judd Apatow and we really witness
that between we saw three versions we
saw the very first cut which was his
starik Alandra moving and then we saw
the second cut which is really dour like
not a funny
it was so dour a lot more angry and then
the actual cut is like a blend of both
it tries to meet it in the middle but
the first guy was still was actually a
pretty amazing movie going experience
for sure
and it really hit that mark that that
Apatow said he wanted to hit wishes he
waited wanted to make a movie that was
like twice as serious as his previous
work in three times as funny
yeah and that cut really did it there's
so many people here every these mention
endgame everyone's gonna hop on the gang
game and we're some childhood once and
guys I'm seeing that some of you guys
actually contributed to our stream labs
we should read some of these off yeah
we've actually were we got a little bit
of a backlog let's go down to Jurassic
room way to John really with enthusiasm
John get some energy up and yes because
I've read none of these with enthusiasm
so far John you were just ever so closer
to the casket but while my first film
experience was Narnia number one and
other the Lion the Witch and the
Wardrobe which is not the first book
funny enough and others have been
memorable like infinity war endgame
Godzilla ko TM I should know what that
is king of the monsters there you go and
justice will for a squirrel following my
personal favorite is King Kong oh five
yes a six year old sat for three hours
happily you know wait wait so you're
only how shall we be so you would have
been six Oh King Kong 2005 yeah yes yes
yes you're like 20 now or 21 ish I don't
know
math anyway a I'm glad to see a little
bit love for that King Kong that King
Kong movie because even though like I
don't think it perfectly hits his mark
it is like a glorious thing to behold in
some way like it's weird it's like super
memorable even though I don't think it
perfectly achieves what it wants - sure
sure but uh but this is a good swathe
man
that's a good swathe glad to see some
Godzilla love even though I didn't love
king of them on
sirs being able to just behold the
monsters on the big screen was pretty
memorable I thought you were gonna say
that's the we swath is every cent swath
yeah I think we're gonna say swastika
like varied image do you know what
you're talking about right now
a swath if you see somebody wearing one
give him a nice good punch in the good
thing he never wears the sleeveless
shirts because tons of markets right you
would not want it up okay never seen
American history so scourge a nice chair
so sheer $19.99 over at stream labs
thank you buddy for contributing over
here guys thanks for these live shows
it's a bloody tonic
yes good times like a pick-me-up drink
my pick is Mad Max fury road oh I went
on a double bill to see Tomorrowland
slash fury road a massive disappointment
followed by an unreal experience that
reminded me of being on a Universal
Studios ride are you saying that fury
road reminded you of being a universal
ride are you saying the experience of
this ride sucks - oh my god this ride is
amazing like oh I just want on
Despicable Me the ride what a piece of
[ __ ] ride but damn now that I went on
the new Jurassic world ride which is
better than all the movies now that's an
experience buddy I haven't gotten to
ride the new Jurassic world ride really
Wow
thank you so steer in 1999 yeah fury
road I was way too high when I watched
that movie smoke way too much pot back
then I saw the wait I could not keep up
with it way too high oh man I saw that
movie I was like at a very it's weird I
was like prepped for that I was with
people who had like more experience with
the overall series but I was like
feeling the hype and I'd seen the
trailer and I knew a couple people who
had seen it and said it wasn't very good
but I was like really excited for it and
then we went and saw it it was
like opening night in the dome and I
just remember being there and being like
a little behind everybody in terms of
like having the full grasp on everything
Mad Max but the energy was just so
enchanting and so exciting and the movie
happened and for me at least my first
viewing experience like it totally hit
and and yeah it was one of those times
where especially - and I don't want a
slight you know you know Marvel style
superhero movies but especially at that
moment in time it was really special to
me because I was like oh wow it's been a
minute since I've seen an action movie
composed and realized with this
sensibility Rises fashion so yeah it was
a very special moving experience guys
thanks so thank you Bernie Sanders bear
bright no soul skier so snow those
Bernice no that was fury road was right
Bernie's panthis three hours of sleep
five straight hours of vomit you saw it
in IMAX 3d
it's Bernie's not Bernie Bernie Sanders
tell me that's not a Bernie Sanders now
I know it's Bernie it's it's Bernice so
you know I don't get the avatar hey I
saw an IMAX 3d while having cold turkey
oxy oh god oh
oxy withdrawals after a major back
surgery I feel for you I've had a back
surgery let's just say it saved my life
and as a top-three goat from me greatest
of all time I'm glad somebody actually
cares and loves avatar and had a special
experience with it as much as I don't
love avatar I had some some special
movie like before the hype happened and
before we all had to go is this really
the best movie of all time based on the
fact that the most people apparently saw
it yeah but yeah I don't know when it
was still just fresh I was pretty
engrossed by it at the very least so I'm
halfway with you I wish I could share
your experience Bernie Sanders III saw
it in IMAX 3d the first time as well but
I was more anal where we have some
stream labs some people are kind of
confused where we differ the stream lab
chats is where we're reading from right
now so some people are super chatting in
the YouTube and also I wanted to quote
Cedric in the chat right now hit the
like button if you're here for John's
birthday
yeah if you like the fact that I was
born let's see here okay so for avatar I
Terminator 2 being my all-time favorite
movie and I really love James Cameron
and at that time he was like gone for 10
years or something right after post
Titanic and in terms of directing a film
and so like whoo I don't think we even
had we're even doing you know news
didn't we weren't even doing YouTube
that so I I was so particular about not
wanting to see anything for literally
didn't know anything about it not a
thing
and whenever a trailer was about to
appear all I remember from the trailer
was someone opening their eyes if I was
in theaters I would leave the theater
that's how anal I was about making sure
I wanted the freshest of experiences
with this film it comes out and whatever
job I had at the time I just couldn't
see it
of course the hype train starts rolling
in everyone's dropping their opinions I
wait I wait to get the perfect seat at
Universal CityWalk IMAX seat m17 that's
my seat go watch avatar and I was like
why don't I like this it's got a lot of
really dazzling packaging around the
story that could have been more unique
very but very bummed out what - but like
it wasn't even was it even like all
these people would hyping it room for me
I think all that combined with my
wanting to not have anything gotta be
perfect yeah like that you get the
perfect experience for an imperfect I
was like because I love James Cameron's
storytelling and it was the storytelling
that led me down and so much so that I
couldn't even get wrapped up in the
visual experience like I wasn't able to
be wowed by it because I was so focused
on the story faulting that's what I
liked that movie is the or is the is the
story faulting you can put a bunch of
other movies in its place and not have
the different experience where should we
where should we should we go back to the
to the main yeah everyone's doing in the
chat Mission Impossible rogue nation
good call
let's see here Blade Runner 2049 Blade
Runner 2049 was a ruined experience for
me because someone ruined the ending for
me during a live stream before we
watched it that's why we don't live
stream on the way to the movies anymore
thank you to everyone who's been going
out of their way to contribute over at
the stream labs page to appreciate that
a lot guys let's see here and Harry
Potter's and Harry Potter Harry Potter's
and the Deathly Hallows photos and the
overcrowded food cafeteria you know I
would say the Dark Knight I'm one of my
one on my notes here the films I want a
list
not just the Dark Knight movie itself
but something a little bit more special
at the time the Dark Knight preview we
yeah I did not know they were doing this
Nolan generally does this for his movies
is because he filmed some of the Himax
cameras and it really pioneered that I
am Legend that's what it was let's go
watch I am Legend and IMAX and I didn't
know they were shooting you know the The
Dark Knight with I'm a didn't know
anything about that and like there was
the first film to do that you know
there's like mass-marketed yeah unless
it was like an IMAX movie that like a
hundred people saw so we we went to see
I am Legend and this thing just starts
playing it's the first 10 minutes of the
Dark Knights the whole bank robbery
scene up right up until the bus leaves
and I didn't know we were watching and
as it was going I was like Joker is this
the Dark Knight is this a trailer and
everything the scope of this screen was
insane
cuz yeah that's like not every IMAX
screen is that large and the IMAX
preview of that experience I was like no
matter what happens we have to watch us
on that's what I became an IMAX junkie
was that was the day was born he does
man not Gemini man I I am Legend only to
return them after the credit trailers
were done oh yeah we would start paying
to go watch I am Legend go trust to go
watch that preview and and then we leave
before the movie started we just
returned and so then yeah and anyway
yeah the IMAX experience of that was
born for me that day and I saw the Dark
Knight at least at least eight times on
IMAX yeah absolutely beautiful beautiful
experience bernie's panners just a
little follow up I just wanna I
appreciate you writing that down avatar
was special to me as I couldn't I
couldn't relate more with Jake being
disabled since childhood and longing for
the feeling of working on the body man
you know that that is a beautiful point
and God I can only imagine that because
yeah like that is such a such a like
breathtaking part of that movie - yeah
yeah yeah appreciate you sharing dude
okay so someone in the chat cocktail
Chomsky just put down another movie I
wanted a list that's not a comic-book
movie and that is actually the Evil Dead
remake now it's not my favorite one of
the evil Dead's like I still definitely
prefer the Raimi films over it but that
movie packs such a punch and I was so
tense the whole time and being a movie
couple in the chair what's up girl so
the but yeah that movie Evil Dead just
like pack such a punch and it was so
violent and the crowd was so muddy was
so like or the whole time and even I was
there oh my god
that evil dad the remake is I don't even
remember the movie as well as I remember
the theater experience in them and the
way of felt being there at time yeah
Natalie teeth on it yeah man well
they'll put sent oh yeah and that was it
yeah that was one of those times going
in it's it's it's not many times lately
I can think of we're like going and
you've got your nerves a bit high cuz
you're like this looks aggressive
motives and everyone's saying it's so
violent yeah and they might have
record-breaking amounts of
blood on set and they delivered them
yeah yeah man I do I do appreciate that
film you know people are saying in the
chat right now Cloverfield that the 2008
movie right cool theater I had a
terrible seat and I was still a cool
theater experience I would say that
honestly I thought the trailer
experience was better than the movie
it's like I loved that I actually I
loved that film I really do but in terms
of what I remember about the theater
experience
I actually associated with the trailer
which I heard recently JJ Abrams was on
Conan O'Brien's podcast
and they said that they shot just that
first before anything else was like
completed and I think that's how the
story basically that was like assembled
solely just for the trailer and then
yeah they never got around the [ __ ]
movie that we got yeah and yeah that
moved that trailer of our being in the
theaters like this looks [ __ ]
terrifying yeah yeah and I guess because
the movie wasn't actually excused tense
but it wasn't scared I mean I thought
the trailer was really scary well in the
trailer was such like a breath of fresh
air and yeah teased you at so many
things
and yeah it's like found footage while
existant was and the phenomenon it
wasn't wasn't the big-budget thing it
was my dad so I feel like yeah the
trailer in and of itself it's like I
liked the movie a lot too but yeah that
trailer just was like such a moment yeah
the trailer got Perry you know oh yeah
Jon bring these bad boys out there bring
the bad boys bad boys what you're gonna
do answer super chats Wow let's see here
let's see here Rizzo gaming so we got
Rizzo gaming read it off Ryan baby
alright Jurassic Park and Star Wars are
important to me and these were the first
ones I saw in cinemas so that was great
19:17 was awesome
because his seventeen man hat happy
birthday John yeah I appreciate that
very much
I mean Jurassic Park in Star Wars are
like
you say what you will about more recent
installments but those are the like
theater those are some of the like Titan
theater movies and it's fascinating to
me now because you know we're watching
people struggle to keep them Titanic
theater going experiences but there's
mainly one person who's struggling Star
Wars out there about movies in general
owe that to the entire everyone's
pushing their movies back while like
months weeks is like I'll push it back
14 days things will change in that
14-day period dude I mean thanks for
pushing it back but also you seem like
somebody who would be taking this
pandemic situation a little more
seriously than like getting back to the
movie I feel like the really super rich
people in the world think a lot of this
is a scam so you think he's detached and
and he's a rich Elon Musk er I don't
know I have no idea I really don't I
don't care I want to see Tennant I have
to watch 10 and opening night on IMAX
come July 31st yeah I respect your
opinion there Ryan Rizzo gaming yeah
1917 was very special to me experience I
really feel like there's a there's a cup
like I think there's a small handful of
movies that came out last year that I
think to truly appreciate them they must
be watching the theaters and and even
though 1917 wasn't my favorite movie of
last year I would say and this is where
people will give me [ __ ] I would say
okay Larry place you like this in terms
of crowd going experiences it easily
goes to endgame for last year right in
terms of let's say the [ __ ] theaters
empty and you're just like there's like
five of you of five other people in the
theater with you which one is the like
vermouth you must watch in the theaters
as well or on IMAX
something like that 19:17 I would say
like to really absorb like that and the
beauty and the breathtaking nature of it
it's like I get if you want to pick
endgame for that but if you're gonna
empty theater which one what I go to
that's a must for a theater experience I
would say it's 1917 yeah just cuz
there's there's a different level of
like cinematic craft converging that is
yes yeah there's just a different timbre
to it which yeah I mean not to slight
the value of seeing like a spectacular
spectacle movie on the big screen but
yeah specially for the tangibility of
something like 1917 being immersed in it
really does add that extra layer of
absolutely a fact
hey we got someone else in the chat Zach
Lyle also his birthday too
wait is it today too though today Zak
Zak actual birthday happy birthday Zach
Lowe a fish
no it's copyright when it's about you
alright happy birthdays a client great
Django Unchained exactly it's great one
right there oh I saw that I had a great
theater experience with that I went with
my dad to the newb of and we saw like
the whole like crazy trailer show and
cartoons they made out and everything
was red Alana's saying in the chat about
don't breathe and yeah that the turkey
baster seen what she's talking about
she's saying in her comments is that
people were like laughing and making
noise and tents and yeah I remember like
being in the theater user Everett you
suddenly chatter everywhere in the
theater at that scene yeah and the whole
thing is reconnected who else is he okay
Britney no Britney laying hey you Thank
You Britney Lange sticker very very day
you see you John that's a Canadian you
you alright
bring back TV 40 iMac yeah any of those
in IMAX have to have been observing yeah
to you a long time to watch cats in
America so we're I'd have liked for us I
remember like sitting you down it was at
Tony's place or her friend Tony and I
was like sitting down going dude I'm
telling you this is a really good Marvel
movie you should watch this man and yeah
yeah I remember you were actually really
impressed with it yeah and yeah I saw it
on IMAX
at the Mann's Chinese Theater which was
awesome you know why I was awesome to
see Civil War at the IMAX Chinese
Theatre because in Iron Man 3 happy
Hogan experiences a bombing we're at
that Mann's Chinese Theater and there
was no bombing than night I went to war
but it was where that scene was shot and
so it felt good to be there well part of
the universe exactly yeah one of the few
la-based scenes in the MCU there but
yeah good call I love your name bring
back TV it was I watched like actual TV
do they have them still like TV at 14 or
20 ma they depending on which network
Nancy you have just listed another movie
that I have on my list right here Thank
You ansible series man it was mainly
it's mainly this one though that she's
pointing out favorite experience Return
of the King opening day we were really
poor then my mom splashed out to take me
with snow that's a great story
splash out of take me with snacks etc
because I love Lord of the Rings
that's a beautiful story that's a
perfect movie for that like that that is
a movie to pull out all the stops on and
make special look how much love you're
getting in this chatt Jon Snow people
are saying happy birthday to you thank
you thank you happy hit that like button
for John thank you so much so yeah I
mean did you see all the Lord of the
Rings in the theaters I did yeah yeah I
mean I've probably saw at least I don't
know if I saw all of them a couple times
but I definitely wound up with a couple
theatrical experiences on two or three
of them yeah and I was if we were as a
family fully wrapped up it's like I went
back and reread
or I tried to reread the books and I
listen to the books yeah because
especially at that time you know like
reading a Harry Potter and Rena Lord of
the Rings are different but yeah now
definitely and especially to see them
stick the landing with the third one and
have like such a cohesive overall
experience like that is a monument of
filmmaking Lord of the Rings and I was
actually I the The Return of the King is
the one I need to finish the trilogy
rewatching because recently I've seen
the extended fellowship and two towers
which they hold up for the most part
incredibly well even still so yeah I
think I was just telling this story to
you wasn't I about the first fellowship
movie the fellowship I actually watched
the bootless it was 2001 it came out and
I saw a bootleg version of it but it was
like when it was on the it was from
another country the bootleg but it was
close to coming out on DVD so it was
like a HD version it wasn't like some
crappy camcorder equality thing and I
didn't see it in theaters I was only 11
years old right now I I'm actually very
much against pirating now especially
with film music I'm a little bit but
with movies especially though so I and I
love that fellowship movie but Return of
the King that was the first one Return
of the King was the first crowd going
experience I've ever had and actually
like you Nancy I went with my mom for I
went with my mom for Christmas it was
Christmas the movie's been out for a
couple weeks at the time I've been
really wanting to watch it and I had
never been to a movie at that age I was
13 years old and I never been with a
crowd where they were just going nuts
the whole time three straight hours of
just pure excitement nuttiness cheering
at everything which was wildly different
to my midnight experience for the two
towers which was very dour because it's
it's the two towers right
but Return of the King [ __ ] that
undoubtably was the very first movie I
ever saw where I was with a crowd that
was like endgame level where people were
just cheering non-stop and you can when
when sad [ __ ] was happening you can hear
the crowd just bawling you know so yeah
[ __ ] a Return of the King is a
hundred percent on my list right now so
[ __ ] yeah I've got some people calling
out Days of Future past Ocean's eleven
that was one I definitely remember going
to see what the family cédric pellet ta
keeping it alive for some you had to
everywhere very happy to see that and a
Hot Fuzz Robert Becerra that actually is
my longest standing 4/20 tradition
because especially back in the do when I
was at Rubik young Angel lad that movie
dropped on 4/20 and at the time I was
like this will be my way of raising the
day watching some my favorite British
comedy let's see who else is here John
read this what does it say
Mohsen summon the flash producer said
flash news coming very soon of course it
is what are you guys expecting
flashpoint recasting new suit a story I
think in the new flash movie that are
casting Hartley Sawyer in it
they're they're bringing him I think I
mean I haven't been following the news
but I think Harley Sawyer who plays a
long gated man is leaving the show to be
in the movie I think that's what's going
on yeah and then Azra Miller is gonna
take Hartley Sawyer's characters place
on the show yes yes so I think that's
what the producer and news must be
that's exactly this point I feel like
the flash movie should just be a docked
one of those documentaries about a movie
they tried to make yes I this has become
such a meme to me that I expect nothing
and I expect that whatever news we do
get is not going to matter but you
probably have a more insightful take
than me I mean it's a bummer of the
Hartley Sawyer [ __ ]
I mean talk about the flasher or
heartless or the whole thing but but you
know if there's if I took this as being
the flash is this gonna be the flash
show producer has news coming or are we
talking about the flash must be the
movie it must be the movie yeah every
scene yeah oh man I don't know what the
[ __ ] the news could be there it's still
happening that's the closest the good
movie news for the DCE you flash movie
it's a it's gonna get I believe one day
it will come it is the New Mutants of
[ __ ] it's really common yeah these
New Mutants exists somewhere as it
completed something I don't know I mean
I'm really hoping the flash movie is
good there's sort of the Harley Sawyer
[ __ ] I gotta say you know like most of
the time now when I hear that you know
someone's been canceled or fired off
with some old ass tweets or something
like that I don't think it's a
black-and-white situation I don't think
it's like all the time it should be
hundred percent yes cancel them 100% no
it's the past you know and when I heard
this I was like man he's from 2013 what
the [ __ ] could he have said when I was
vomiting last night I couldn't and I
couldn't sleep I was just in the
bathroom by the toilet I just decided to
just like I'm just gonna distract my
mind let me go on the internet and I
decided to lure the Harley spirit to its
I don't like this messed up he's just
bad jokes then I kept going I was like a
certain point cuz then I thought back
and I was like and I did I haven't
looked up like the old James Gunn tweets
but I was thinking back and being like I
remember having some of these feelings
but where were his jokes like as clearly
there was something where I was like
even yeah even if you're joking this
that's not a parent yeah or or at least
joking in a way that's like satirical
where you're like no I don't at all like
legitimately support or find this money
what I can't handle is the the top but
like if you're if you're like honestly I
could believe
Grant Gustin did not see those tweets I
could even believe the showrunner did
not see those tweets in the past since
but the amount of [ __ ] cuz it's like
honestly I don't even know what I tweet
every year you know and so now I get a
little weird like that some [ __ ] joke
like that on Twitter but when I think
about the like the top of the top the
people who are really in charge of
drawing up the money for these [ __ ]
you know like the people at WB or
something who always act like they never
knew about any of this [ __ ] and they're
like we don't condone this at our
company and like it's a great statement
and all and I am at the same time like
there's gotta be you must have known
they say you're like especially even
even were going back to like the Disney
James Gunn's I'm like you must have
known he said some [ __ ] and then acting
like what and that's always a response
from these companies the companies are
always like like I wonder what the sitch
was for him because especially in a lot
of actors especially if you're in the
position I would imagine to be on like a
network television show you've got to
have social media as a part of your
business model as a part of your
business presence so yeah I'm a little
surprised that maybe he just totally
forgot or like nobody was looking but
yeah like the fact that these were able
to just resurfaced and blindside
everybody is a little suspect strange I
mean like James Gunn seemed wackier in
the sense that I'm like his whole
filmography up until that point would
suggest some off-color humor like if you
look where he came from and like Troma
movies and stuff well yeah yeah so I
don't know I guess it's like more
surprising in a way to me due to that
guy's image but uh goodbye elongated man
Oh what do we got here Britney laying
Thank You Britney Lange John read it off
it's for you happy birthday John have a
wonderful day I am this far it's been a
nice day
I appreciate that did you notice
something Britney Lang did what did she
did change her profile pic again and
again that's the way she rolls
like an algorithm that just change your
own Michael Swift you guys seen the
trailer for jus on origins I know is
that now I don't know why I'm asking
this but I feel like I heard a piece of
news that that's not a show is it it's
it's a film is it another Jew on The
Grudge film I would hate a Jew on yeah
sounds like a terrible idea
are there J horror TV series in the vein
of something like a haunting of he'll
cuz like part of me thinks that not
doing it would you on but like you could
do a J horror TV show that would be
super chilling yeah because especially
those things are often wrapped up in
ghosts and human anguish and stuff so
like it would lend itself to expansion
but no I have seen the last trailer I
saw that involved kyuk-ho
was I think the Tzadik over Sky Country
I think it was a grudge three was the
last one we saw it so the grocery
trailer or yeah wait with those hey
Brendan V hey doing buddy doing all
right you own origins is a show I mean
with the way how repetitive those
[ __ ] movies are I'm like what can you
get out of a show again yeah like do a
supernatural shame or so repetitive what
is is The Grudge Lord just so David
Gandy thank you for such a major [ __ ]
contribution here see regular comment we
won't let will dig through the drama to
going to go all the way to the regular
comments you know we take all these
questions
garnet maybe we can do a control go for
it John we're in an app this is an
actual website so okay well no see if we
find it don't look for your chat David
Gandy that's all we got in regular
comment but that's - of - where's David
gained oh no I found out there hey guys
I know you've been burning the candle
tens thanks for your hard work happy
belated birthday John number one Star
Wars back in 77 number two Return of the
King
opening day seeing it twice he's not
twice I am I've never done that watch
this I mean I did it with Mortal Kombat
but I was six years old and I was forced
to with my dad I think we miss like the
first five minutes it's particular
that's where I get it from and so I
wanted to see but yeah I mean you know I
wish I caught one of the Star Wars
releases in the theaters yeah it could
have been even [ __ ] episode one and I
would have been content like 77 80 or 83
either one of those would have been
great to catch in the theaters but I
didn't catch any of those in the rear
releases and I'm I'm bummed about that
guys get to a hundred likes for Jon's
birthday thank you let's get to a
hundred likes we've got two more to go
two likes two more to go than were then
we're there for Johnny's Burghley
succeeded Oh
David Gandy rush hour - uh-huh
croc skin butter cream you know it's
funny I saw rush hour 2 in the theaters
everyone was cracking up the whole time
your dad part of the Directors Guild of
America he got a screen to go watch rush
hour 2 and I went with you and your dad
no one was laughing through most of the
movie they were not into it at the DGA
yeah you know when they laughed the
bloopers that's what I remember that
specifically the bloopers when everyone
was laughing oh I mean I still had a
good experience but that's a bummer I
guess it's not quite a directorial kind
of movie I understand that you know
everybody at the time was just very
aware of what would become a Brett
Ratner and they were getting a head
start on [ __ ] this we're not laughing at
[ __ ] a lot of people the chatter saying
that our my voice is in their right ear
in your voices and their left and people
are making their ASMR jokes
we are the loudest ASMR you've ever had
in your
life man hey as Samaras underrated
alright let's go here John read it off
Peter Pacheco wants to know happy
birthday John great shirt from a great
anime all thanks to this G over here
best theater-going experience end of
infinity war everybody pretty much
crying yeah man I remember when we saw
infinity war there was literally a
person dressed as spider-man weeping for
spider things where it was one of the
special moments were like it was people
were crying and sniffling but like this
person was like so very moved and it was
one of those moments where I had two
reactions because part of me was like
wow you're very very into this but I was
also like you're very into this and
that's kind of beautiful I thought it
was obnoxious I even see even her lover
had to be like what she was like it's
we're not watching Schindler's List you
know when you hear people in the theater
crying you're like [ __ ] people were
crying yeah yeah this girl was like like
she was sobbing like and like if a
family member just passed or something
hey you know maybe that's what happened
maybe she checked off in the future to
inspire trivialize that person's
emotional let's do one more here than we
got a few in the stream labs we needed
cover - Lana Pete go happy birthday hey
Lana
hey hey some faves are Jurassic Park in
first grade and being terrified is a
scary ass movie and game for obvious
reasons Starship Troopers because a
friend picked it for my birthday and we
knew nothing about it I loved it happy
birthday again thank you thank you Lana
so sweet of you that's a movie I need to
to go back and re-watch Starship
Troopers I remember vividly when it was
coming out but I was very much not
involved with that Jurassic Park was the
first movie I saw in the theaters Lana
okay
scream my head off three years old
freaking out the whole [ __ ] yeah you
should not take a little kid to go watch
that yeah that was [ __ ] that was
terrifying
you'd forget like once you become 12
it's easy to forget that's a scary movie
yeah mom is such a great follower of
ours so maybe you guys have been to pee
I could recognize so many of these names
somebody reoccurring names but guys we
got some stream labs we got a we got a
cover to think everyone has contributed
in the stream laboratory all right let's
see how behind we are here we are on
Hudson I mean oh wait okay no no no no
we're way behind oh my god from June 6
no John I am reading incorrectly all
right John
take it away happy birthday old man
thank you
my favorite threat that's my favorite
theater-going experience wasn't for a
movie it was for a live musical the
Texas State University production of
Little Women and that was sorry the
Texas State University production of
Little Women was that good which film
should I watch next Jerry Maguire or
Capote you would you should watch the
first half of Jerry Maguire then last
half of the last show and see what you
can review it as if that was the way it
was meant to be watched and criticized
how uneven it felt by the structure of
the experience you have that cake and
eat it too thanks hitman Hudson so but
in all honesty I would say Jerry Maguire
um I'll just play devil's out you'll
have a better time watching Jerry
Maguire obviously but [ __ ] German
greats Philip Seymour Hoffman is a great
actor so scourge a 1999 thanks buddy
he's saying in our stream lads over here
I love to see a classic in a cinema for
the whole theatrical experience I love
to see Blade Runner
Terminator 2 or 2001
have you done this in LA and if so what
were some of your favorites actually on
my list right here Terminator 2 they
re-released it in 3d which is pretty
awesome and my girlfriend and never seen
it before and it was one of those things
where I'm like I don't know what will
happen to a relationship if she doesn't
like this movie Terminator to the
theaters she [ __ ] loved it that was a
great experience and there was no other
matrix they rereleased that awesome they
remastered the whole quality was
breaking beautiful there's I saw the
first time I saw ET was at an arc light
presents and it was so that was a
rerelease of ET and first time I ever
saw that was action in the theaters and
I feel like there's another one oh my
god we we we went to Roman Holiday a
very old classic film in the theaters oh
yeah that was that was great so seen a
lot of John you see pretty good amount
of rear elisa's of classic cinema
theaters having yeah yeah I mean
definitely in terms of like
well-respected classics especially
around like the holidays I mean I've
seen It's a Wonderful Life I've seen
white Christmas on the big screen I saw
em the Peter Lorre movie about the the
infamous child killer
that which was like especially watching
those like old noir tales on the big
screen is really fascinating and
transport of experience especially when
you see the contrast between what has
changed in terms of what you couldn't
allow but also what hasn't changed in
terms of how impactful and how heavy the
subject matter can be yeah so yeah I've
definitely caught a handful of like
classics but also you know I've seen
some cult classics as well there are a
lot of fun I'll never forget seeing like
sleepaway camp
for the first time in a movie theater
and I think that may have been the first
time I watched no I'm not sure if that
was the first time I had ever seen it or
not but uh but yeah I got I got a lot of
like LA is definitely a hotbed for that
kind of thing there at least - at the
moment theater what at one of them
imploded for having a bunch of sex
offenders run it because that culture is
alive and well in this city but but yeah
there are a few places that like
consistently
outside of quarantine play old revival
movies and stuff like that
I got to see Robocop actually in our
school college movie theater which was
rad so I don't know yeah they're a bunch
Thanks bunch o class thanks so CJ thank
you all right we got jurassic room here
thank you for contributing in our stream
labs he says or she says I'm assuming
it's a he because I roll that way my
first ever experience was first over
movie theater experience
Narnia number one and while of oh wait
oh did you contribute this twice I think
this is a slightly updated I was
wondering this too and I think it's a
slightly updated by the way happy
birthday John okay and rises Skywalker
was my first Star Wars film ever saw
okay I get it set up they way Jay de
vincennes they'll stand by them till
they saw all the Jurassic world films
Rises Skywalker was the first Star Wars
film favorite movie experience King Kong
oh five and happy birthday John closer
to the casket that's right guys John has
been diagnosed with a terminal illness
so go over to our stream labs and help
fun I want to walk man in the coffin lid
have people done that at they they faked
an illness to get like a go fund me yes
I'm sure that's happened
well I'm sure that that's happened and
also there are people who have like have
you ever heard that story of gypsy Lee
Rose whose mom like poisoned her for
years yeah and then she the girl and her
boyfriend like killed hurt like yeah now
we can't do it because I just put it out
there and I'm like I have people done it
there's now we can sure there was a
GoFundMe campaign some guys set up that
was literally called help me make potato
salad and it made so much money that he
actually started making and like
alright we got two back-to-backs here
from hitman Hudson thank you dressing
room for that by the way
hitman Hudson saying what is the
greatest Nicole Kidman performance also
do you think a Legion of super-heroes
movie would work or would there be too
many characters to balance my favorite
personal nicole kidman performance would
have to be from
little lies I think she's absolutely
incredible in that show and it's easy my
favorite performance of hers or to die
for where she stars with Joker Atlanta
choker oh my god cinematic possible and
legion is Johnny's Inc the Legion of
super-heroes part um well anyway the
Legion of super-heroes yeah I think
it'll probably work ish I mean it all
depends on how you get who you get to
write the ensemble I feel like Avengers
and Gaiman infinity war while there are
complaints I think you can especially
with infinity war level at those movies
about being overloaded to the point you
can't really get to know your characters
or spend a lot of intimate time with
them they rely on you having all that
information already that being said I
don't think it's impossible given enough
time and space they're also my favorite
Nicole Kidman performance is the others
that's a great one love that right call
great call and then it's follow up here
at stream labs my best movie theater
experience was event you know I feel
like for a lot of people genuinely
though they'll mean it sincerely
Avengers endgame will probably be their
favorite movie theater experience ok I
can believe that you know oh yeah not
just cuz it's new but I really think
like the build-up and for what that
movie meant in the theaters and the
crowd like I can see how that can be
people's favorite experience oh yeah I
mean I look at myself and I think ok
like these these movies like this kind
of movie isn't my absolute favorite kind
of movie but even I like in that moment
a special in the climactic moments of
end game was like cathartic Lee overcome
so like if I had that experience I can
only imagine like that is a totally
cathartic memorable and one of those
where I feel like even if you're not
fully invested just seeing them stick
that landing is like really gratifying
and he goes on to say which I saw my
friend Cary Caleb and Jordan sure shouts
lots of those other efforts are they
your friends I know a Caleb I'm sure I
know I know people by each of these
names but I feel like
I thought it was nice as a shout some
other folks out would I don't know maybe
they'll watch back and feel nice about
hearing their names spoken by us he says
who is hotter Chris Hemsworth in Thor or
Greg Alba in this live stream oh that's
no question and it's obviously [ __ ]
Greg albums live your sexier than
anywhere you're looking is a man here at
Thor short-haired Thor game or Thor you
name it you're sexier than all of them
I'm probably a little sexier than fat
Thor you're a lot sexier than I thought
maybe don't sell yourself short
okay so where are we at here John yeah
get me back on okay we're right here
Erica Tuesday the cut Josh are the
closest friends you read it off saw the
American president while sitting next to
Walter Matthau damn don't remember [ __ ]
about the movie but the looks we staged
with me are burned into my brain forever
I have your birthday John love you babe
I love you too I love you I just want to
know what looks he was killing you know
I was funny is actually just just the
other day I was like asking John about
you I was like what is there it could do
it like she didn't he was tell me about
I don't know if I'm allowed to talk
about it on the stream so but he was
talking about some stuff that's going on
with your career and now I was I was the
one who's like it just inquiring about
like well like I know she does animation
but what exactly the animation does she
do and and so yeah I'm happy to hear
about all this success Java that is a
great story reminds me when we saw The
Simpsons
yeah we were next to Gary Oldman yeah it
was also a math or even in the American
president let's find it just was he just
there wow just really wanted to see that
that's a fun story and she donated and a
lot and this in the stream labs you
six-six-six thank you
trademark Devil tip okay let's see here
okay I will pick up the rest of these
stream labs in a little bit what else is
in this chat here Pacific Rim was
honestly like Pacific Rim is not one of
my movie master in the chat saying this
specific brand is not one of my favorite
movies but that was an IMAX
perience I adored and convinced a couple
of people to go check it out embrace I
convinced you to go check it yeah like
you gotta watch this an IMAX dude yeah
that one an overwhelming experience in a
very cool way yeah hey thank you for
everyone in the chat who's like really
pushing to get those uh those likes up
but so so sweetie you got 13 theaters or
Channel streaming theaters faders yeah
let's see here it's not a special just
streaming so instead heard of Kobe for
the first time through rush hour - how
funny when did you first see his song
says hey John what's your girl type any
girl yeah my type is pretty broad I
guess I would say I mean like there's
probably you know how like when you
listen to music you probably have like a
Homebase main stage genre that like you
know you like but I don't know I'm open
to a lot of things he's open anything
girls just send him some new tees he'll
talk with you that's simple and this are
you listening
hey Nyssa she said hey thank you and
Nisa Harry Potter's Deathly Hallows Part
1 and 2 or another one of my favorite
moments I saw all the Harry Potter was
my brother and it was amazing that's
great dude some rad especially like
that's a special sharing experience
between like siblings to the I think you
uh you you've seen like every Harry
Potter movie with your family right
mm-hmm
yeah every single one especially now as
of a couple weekends ago when I watch 6
7 & 7 - yeah yeah I'm my favorite one my
favorite one is I think everyone's least
favorite its Deathly Hallows Part 1
Village Chamber of Secrets and Hallows
Part 1 seem to be like though generally
or talked to be the least favorite ones
and and to me Deathly Hallows Part 1 is
actually my favorite one I mean the
thing is I watched them close enough
together that they are not like super
separated in my mind but I like Deathly
Hallows more once again
well thank you Aneesa never lose your
nerd and ever and ever that's a great
title I mean you can't have me if you're
a real nerd it's in here here
all right never lose your nerd says god
what are you looking at I'm still trying
to find Walter Matthau and I don't think
he's let it go John
never lose your head Godzilla king of
the monsters love the action that's
actually a movie theater experience I'll
never forget what God's looking in the
monsters because we saw them 40x yes and
the 40x on that [ __ ] was [ __ ] nuts it
was so much smoke heat and one like
raining half the movies the water is
always on and the image the image is
already [ __ ] nuts on screen like even
if you're not in a crazy like
everything's moving around
yeah this image is already nuts so
combine that together and we had Jason
Dolan go with it like that was a I was a
but I actually took a toll on district 9
yes I never forget the first time I saw
a district I was one of those those like
that's always a really special
experience to me when like a movie comes
out of kind of nowhere by like people
you don't necessarily know and really
grabs hold like that yes one of my
favorite movies for sure happy birthday
JD star-lord happy early birthday let's
go back here and then we got blue iris
Jon read it away
whiplash was amazing in theaters am i
rushing or dragging I was only I was the
only one there wow that's a that's a
movie to watch by herself I felt like he
was yelling at me came in worried tell
me to stop drumming that movie is it's
I've only seen it the ones but it
definitely stuck with me I'll say that
dude [ __ ] Jay jonah jameson so scary
in that so scary
but thank you never lose your nerd know
those blue iris I mean sorry Peter
Pacheco another Gemini man another
another Gemini mine my birthday oh yeah
another Gemini mine is next Saturday did
you learn Portuguese yet
okay happy early birthday to you Peter
Pacheco yes did you learn any Portuguese
I have not but I'm moving to Brazil next
week as a wolf awesome great to hear but
thank you so much Peter Pacheco dream
chaser dream chaser I love this guy's
name dream capturer
do you take other people's dreams away
Johnny what's up guys best theater
experience might be Aquaman on IMAX I
felt like I was in Atlantis love y'all
and we love you too that uh what Aquaman
yeah yeah I did I convinced you we went
to IMAX that's right you Jesus John but
yeah I remember every single time you
want to go watch a movie with your other
best friend Aaron but the movies with me
oh yeah whatever
dick I am a dude you're a dick [ __ ] your
birthday yeah this should be your did
you already have like a few birthdays
already get over yourself were you gonna
do another one next year
how's the 3d audio working out for you
guys it's around Sam is meant to be
listened to on like a 5.1 system several
subwoofers chirp speakers everywhere
shouts out to dreamchaser thanks buddy
Zachary skulls what a great name I saw
force awakens five times and theaters
loved it and to this day my opinion
hasn't changed
don't let anyone try to convince you to
change your opinion star wars is great
all hail Disney I only wish the movies
that followed were better yeah I'm glad
you at least had that experience yeah I
mean I'm right there with you Zachary
like I watched force awakens first time
opening night like a lot of people loved
it then we watched it again the very
next day and then I was like all right
let's go a third time let's do this IMAX
baby then after that I was like I don't
think I want to watch this movie anymore
I'm over this now I'll wait for this to
come out on DVD this is so much it's a -
oh yeah my brain's exhausted I want to
move on to a different movie yeah
favorite food I'll kill your brother I
think my favorite food might be sushi
his YUM
his all right so yes dink a Stubbs to
see the name all right so we got okay
we'll do a speed round of anis us here
Jon oh wow nice that's thank you thank
you so much
triple feature of Annisa thank you we go
even though thank you even though it
wasn't my first time watching it the
Rocky Horror Picture Show midnight
showing I go to every year close to
Halloween the entire audience
some people go every week or month
really the entire audience interacts
with the movie and it's become a
tradition I love that's awesome I mean
and that is a that is a well-worn
community tradition that is a good one
also Greg I hear you in my right ear and
John in my left ear talking about still
waiting on y'all to make an ASMR lol
everyone would enjoy it I am for it also
shouts out whoever in the chat said 8d
audio cuz uh is that still a thing I
remember like a week remember was like
this eighty audio phenomenon so dumb
but anyway pigs way way really quick on
off of that thought Anissa well because
I was feeling so sick last night and I
couldn't sleep I actually tried out an
ASMR video to help me sleep and it
worked
Billy yeah their soothing right yeah I
was touching myself all night now no I I
actually couldn't sleep and it was it
was helping cuz I noticed that if I
listen to I was trying my mind off
things there was something about having
other someone else's voice in my head I
don't remember the video I don't
remember who which channel it was it
wasn't like super popular ones but yeah
it's first time I ever tried it out and
it actually did really help me out
underrated underrated genre of content
or medium I don't think it's underrated
it's super [ __ ] popular it's very
much acknowledged one of the most cloud
on genres
it's not he's very popular yeah I've
been it's one that people clown on even
though they see yeah
aneesa's final for this run says the
Polar Express was the first movie I ever
saw in IMAX on a school field trip and
it's still a super special memory for me
I'm glad you have a good memory
associated with that movie yeah because
I remember seeing him in the theaters
and I liked it okay I remember being a
little creeped out by the uncanny valley
but that sounds like a really cool
school trip to do like especially like
like was this for some kind of holiday
thing because especially yeah like to go
to see IMAX for school that's awesome
mm-hmm
yeah Polar Express I saw an IMAX - I did
love that movie and Rocky Horror Picture
Show still haven't seen oh they'll have
not seen a couple minute one this COBIT
[ __ ] is over with I'm gonna take Olivia
to go watch it that's one of them cold
showings yeah go the new art or they
sacrifice people on stage and we all
cheer yeah that's what they do right
yeah say murder people the Rocky Horror
Picture Show only place is legal the do
[ __ ] bizarre so thank you for your
multiple back-to-back super chats in
this that is very sweet of you yes
let's read off some of these stream labs
hold on hold on let's read one more to
set something straight because Bernie
spanner says yes it's a female version
of Bernie wasp and a name so thank you
Thank You Bernie
I don't know if that actually cleared it
up it does we going back to the stream
labs
yeah it's go right here really yeah
let's see who we got next we got
Jurassic room again crap
didn't realize I donated twice oh well
but hey Peter Jackson's King Kong turns
15 this year so go team Godzilla or
surprise are you - yeah team Godzilla or
team Kong
by the way Godzilla vs. Kong is delayed
till May 21st son of a [ __ ] 21 what
it's too late to take food you're alive
I'm uh I would say I mean if I think
between a fight between Godzilla and
King Kong I would say Godzilla but I
think I'm still like more of a Kong fan
at heart for the staple and cinema as an
American because I stand by my American
side as America's great I don't know if
you guys have been following the news
we've got [ __ ] in order if you don't
think so you can get honest li haven't
seen enough Godzilla films or enough
King Kong I mean I've seen more coffee I
haven't seen enough Godzilla films to
properly conclude that but I by my heart
right now is at King Kong John my heart
goes to Godzilla but that's probably
because I mean yeah I grew up with the
I've actually held one of the original
Kong armatures from that movie which is
different stories like those I
definitely got love in my heart for Kong
but especially growing up I was big into
Godzilla and I like the they both have
that sort of ecological protector thing
sure especially as Godzilla grows and
gets more nuanced I'm like I feel for
you I'm just trying to live peacefully
and keep the ecology of the earth in
alignment that all this nonsense keeps
waking you up so uh I don't know it's a
close one but I'll go team Godzilla for
me no it's great thanks Marvel pays me
just to pay you came and say anything in
the comment just says Marvel pays me
thank you for your contribution that's
further that's our up front for the
positive like we appreciate ya oh yeah
Black Widow best movie of the year
[ __ ] Wonder Woman I don't believe writes
all about black widow dachshund what a
cool name Hawk d aw xen dachshund with
Luna Lovegood father's name oh hold on I
know this it's um
I do know it and I need to take a pause
and the problem is I'm gonna be like I
don't want to leave a dead space on the
livestream
chat what is but I love Goods father's
name his name I know it I know it
Xenophilius is very good that's how the
ex that's what made me think of oh smart
yeah yeah good sometimes I'm trying
membership for O'Donnell
[ __ ] out like not acted out but like
there's a [ __ ] acting class it's a
good acting class now like like who's
the who's the captain of the enterprise
in the first Star Trek movie and I had a
hard time member's name and then I was
like oh it's okay his first name is
Willard so think of Crispin Glover and
so I have an emotional association to
the name it sounds like Willard Eckhart
okay got it now and Xenophilius when I
was trying members Xenophilius his name
from Harry Potter I do this like what
can help me get there and it's a real
note y'all are the best reactors in the
planet oh thank you so much you know who
would agree with you everyone who
watched our ps5 hardware revealed like
to dislike oh my god like almost no
dislikes reaction to appreciate that
happy birthday John you're the goat is
what he says that never gets old dear I
appreciate ya people tell them that all
the time you're the goat constantly
referred to as a positive really current
slang term so I'm gonna keep this as
much as I can I didn't know what a goat
meant until I saw until I heard the
Eminem song goat and where he just
explains what goat means in the song
yeah you know they make cheese and make
this [ __ ] the coats make the cheese milk
1 and also sausage party in theaters
wasn't saying I can't imagine what it
Wow what would that have been like like
watch that finale in the theatres oh
damn a sausage party that would be
[ __ ] bizarre that seems like a movie
that perhaps its best potential would
rely on being in a boisterous group like
that yeah cuz like I remember when we
watched it at home it was okay you watch
them with your family no I thought we
watched it I thought yeah I thought we
no I didn't i watch TV i watch it now he
said watch at home I'm gonna assume you
watch it with your family well home at
the time was was our home well specify
John we think I can't just assume you
want to assume you make an ass out of
you and me you know what my family like
rented deem America they brought it into
the house yes smart on them we got
through it it was good it was by Daniel
Dholavira SIA by creative gaming how off
the rails is a stream comparatively not
really crazily off the rails but it's a
little officer it's it's a frame like
we've gone further off the rails before
it so we know normally it's like bananas
[ __ ] crazy because honestly I think a
lot has to do with the fact that I
cannot over exert my energy normally
here's here's know only how the streams
go guys
I'm very hyperactive in the first hour
and then I start to feel a little bit
like I'm crashing around an hour and a
half
I go wow I'm in loopy lamb territory I'm
gonna do every [ __ ] I want now and
then we're just way off the rails
this one I'm fairly consistent
throughout steady a steady steady time
here Oh Greg will always be Dean I love
that you're Sam I'm Dean supernatural
baby that's perfect
alright yeah people know we further gone
off the rails before when I'm feeling
better next week we'll go way off the
rails
well intentionally do it to the point
where it's not even charming it's just a
noxious and no idea my birthday
September 3rd all right John let's uh Oh
where'd it go dude you know both of our
birthdays are like divisible zuv 3 6 and
12 and 3 and 9 3 6 9 12 I am just as
impressed by this as you are that's cool
that's cool numbers those are cool
numbers shut up you don't know anything
yeah
I hate you okay that's why I was always
doing poorly because I just want to
spend more time with them I knew what I
was doing
hitman Hudson over at stream lab says
have y'all seen sergeant York if so what
are your thoughts I saw it on TCM once
with my dad and I loved it I'm sorry I
have not seen sergeant your have you as
it must be an old John you know looking
it up here would be so much faster
it's a 1941 film Cooper starring Gary
Cooper who I wonder if Olivia seen it my
girlfriend's a major loves like main
main genres classics and then the last
stream lab one that we currently have at
the moment we'd like to wrap by 730
issue today to be honest I got so much
steam in the engine right check the
[ __ ] super chat this is a test hey we
got your super debate see what Eric your
inner super chest and you're here he's
spreading the lung he's just going
around everywhere well thank you Eric
horseman means a lot buddy
and speaking of actually just because
your previous hit man your previous
comment brought this to my mind I did
get to see the Texas Chainsaw Massacre
on a big screen at one point that was a
very cool experience but also like that
experience when they released the
remastered blu-ray or whatever that was
one where it's like I already had like
an affection for that movie but that was
like being immersed in it I was like
yeah I know I love ya so I got a very
cool experience let's see here oh and
the chat oh we got a really nice
compliment here Priscilla's saying I
just want to say you guys are so awesome
handsome and I adore you
oh yeah Priscilla well I feel the same
way about me too dude you know the other
day you got a comment about you wearing
your gray Batman shirt and it was
driving somebody in the comments who was
a lady white quite quite mad with with
lustful desire no wow like whenever
Gregoire is that Batman shirt it was a
guy dressed as a girl John let's face
facts you know it's different all right
hey Maria Hammond see you later
just friending you on facebook well
natural friend of mine windy area what's
up we've got a lot of people in this
chat right now thank you guys for being
here
Cedric Pelletier has been killing it in
this chat all holding it down at Scott
Pilgrim yes that's a good one
gosh peak Ellen was the best chat I've
ever been in yes it was a great day
Jason Jones you said I want to see jaws
this weekend you didn't go to it to a
Tennessee driving did you actually I
know somebody else who went and saw jaws
this weekend as well let's see here Oh
John let's bring this back up
petitioner permanently replaced John
with Juliet sir oh it's a row is the
girl from Campea who came on here right
redhead girl yeah dude really really
friendly person yeah no that's not the
same do go silver
oh yeah let's do the thing
but with quality quality attention do go
silver quiet place was amazing that was
a good theater experience too first
movie I've ever seen the main an entire
audience go completely silent not even
anyone reaching into their snack bags or
crunching on popcorn that's exactly what
I want to comment on because a woulda
made me think of was whenever I went to
the theaters and my mom and I'm sure
whenever I go back to the theaters with
her again she's gonna do the same exact
thing she always gets like a large
[ __ ] bucket I got a random side to
engin story for you guys thanks for just
subscribing Jason Jones Wilson says hi
Greg happy birthday Wilson so have you
guys seen the movie 28 days later the
most awkward experiences I've ever
actually as someone in the chat asked
what's the weirdest horror movie
experience I've ever had and this
definitely qualifies from my personal
life so in 28 days later
I would go to church every Sunday
Catholic Church Mass and then for some
reason I just had seen the trailer for
it and I went to bed I took a nap woke
up and I was like kind of want to see
that over that random trailer movie you
wanted to watch him up and because at
time Costco would have these gold
tickets for AMC there were only six
bucks a ticket that you buy it there so
you only spend six bucks or let's just
go watch this movie go to watch 28 days
later not really knowing what it's good
what its gonna be like and the theaters
packed so I have to sit by my cell phone
my mom always has to get popcorn I'm
sitting by myself to watch 28 days later
and my mom's getting popcorn the whole
opening starts the whole [ __ ] opening
of 28 days later starts with over though
they're monkeys or something rage cut to
[ __ ] kill Ian Murphy laying dick out
and everything right just completely
nude my mom walks in the theater the
first thing she sees is a dick on screen
and I just see her looking at the screen
and then turning around and I mom sat
down by yourself watch to my point where
you think of that was my mom when she
eats popcorn in the theater it is nine
times out of ten we could be watching
the loudest [ __ ] Michael Bay movie
and she won't start eating her popcorn
until there's a talking see it's quiet
she tends to wait for when there's not
something loud I'm like you should be
eating when it's loud not because she's
allowed Scheuer River C issue it was
like quiet intentions though I'm glad I
didn't see a quiet place because that
wouldn't bother her two [ __ ] she would
have been someone's requesting a new
rock stars infinity saga re-watch
breakdown Rio Jesus Christ Sol skier 99
about the Red Hot Chili Peppers I just I
had to take a mole john frusciante he's
coming back he's coming back all right
who's next he next his next on the
Zachary sculls retracted one message I
don't know what that was but he also
says happy birthday John Thank You
Zachary appreciate holy [ __ ] thank you
Eric you late again
I hope this you don't do this some more
in this chat but thank you crap late af
again
can't use stream lat well did you
streamline can't you stream loves
because my paypal was hacked FML anyway
happy birthday John thanks buddy that's
very very very very generous of you
don't worry about the tardiness
whatsoever I hope that that that little
nudge on stream labs has not destroyed
your financial sense my god be safety
don't don't [ __ ] overspend like I'd
say this for everyone here if you if you
happen to contribute to stream lab is a
super chat you know don't don't break
your wallet I just be comfortable
appreciate it though and no refunds yeah
[Laughter]
greetings to the Dominican Republic okay
but the ban that's a lot Eric horseman
follow that up with another crazy one
oh Jesus Christ the 13th part three cuz
it was my first 3d experience anyone
remember the multicolored glasses and we
were high as [ __ ] I was 11 to hung wall
which made it even better
Wow what were you high on at 11 Erica I
wanted oh my god I would imagine some
kind of method LSD something like that
your imaginary going very hard at that
age Thank You grant but Eric horseman
that's correct
I'm when I was studying for this Ramona
I once I saw that trailer for Friday I
haven't seen them actual movie oh wait
no park yeah part three no I haven't
seen it the one where they said we like
3d comes to be yeah that's crazy
yeah and that's that it's got a
a lot of very 3d gag type gags well
thank you so much Eric that's very kind
of you or overwhelmingly generous and I
appreciate you very much and then what
do we got here Oh Brendan thank you Eric
again series Envy for my best theater
experience is probably two years ago
seeing Natasha Pierre and the great oh
ho oh look at this [ __ ] look at
this [ __ ]
we asked favorite theater-going
experience and the handsome man
Brendan V goes I'm gonna take this
question so literal I'm gonna talk about
like Broadway [ __ ] not even oh you meant
the feet all right yes I saw fences live
the one that won the Tony performance
with Denzel Washington and then I saw
the movie and had a flashback oh boy
that's awesome though the great comet of
1818 12
thank you for your super check wicked on
Broadway is definitely there to double
damn man you know we have a we have the
Pantages Theatre right here where they
often bring the live shows and I've
never caught one of them you know like
Book of Mormon wicked Lion King there's
so many shows that were like those great
brought these musicals that Roommate
adhere to la never cut what's is there
one going on obviously not right now but
this is one that should be coming here I
want to make sure we go I want to check
one of them out oh if I'm not mistaken I
think Hamels is supposed to come back so
that would be prime but I think like
spongebob the musical is supposed to
open when the
at the Pantages anyway when the
quarantine descended but I'll have to
look because they usually have a few
shows yeah
the rotate out so uh but yeah it is a
special experience over there it is
really cool especially if you can get a
good show cuz I got to I got to see
wicked at the Pantages which was really
special
I got to see Book of Mormon and I got to
see Hedwig was was really cool as about
Harry Potter's bird yeah this is a whole
biography and it's all hooting it's just
open to interpretation ever you want
completely right Erika you will yeah we
can the Angry Inch Thank You Brandon V I
hope you're feeling better about your
way it's this is not vodka if I had
vodka right now I'd just be throwing up
some more I'm telling you let's see here
where we ads oh my god I scrolled way
too far it's okay it's okay go down
we're in the up we're up okay there's
Eric horseman there's Brendan V Rizzo
gaming is next rizzo gaming Commons
black lives matter and trans lives
matter it's a tenant lives it said black
lives matter and tenon lives yeah John
David Washington is the stars headed
yeah yeah man yes to both yes and aka
Rowling's life matter she's doing
wonders for the pottery community right
now yeah yeah and she's really picking
the right time to do so absolutely and
guys I want to mention we we raised in
total with the fund raisers that we did
and with the live stream last week we
raised about well you see okay let me
take this again take two on the live
stream let's sort that out yeah we've
raised over thirty five hundred dollars
in total and the haven't posted on the
community page yet because we've already
got receipts for the other ones but the
ones from the super chats from last week
for the stream the ones that were
specifically super chat and not stream
lab
those won't get to us until the 21st of
next month right yeah so then when we
pay that out I have to screenshot I
already have a screenshot of how much
was made that day and then I got to show
the proof that we put that much towards
the donation so yeah yeah absolutely
Rizzo gaming Ryan baby thank you buddy
for bringing that up especially now that
it is Pride Month and there have been
some pretty nasty yaps against black
trans people lately so yeah I mean and
there have been for a long time but yeah
trans lives very minor both yeah Chris
bliss my favorite movie experience was
getting a chance to see the Irishman
thank you that's on the list right here
thank you Chris bliss there you go mr.
Chris bliss don't dismiss Chris bliss
he's on my Christmas wish list call him
Chris bliss
Chris bliss wedding from the pits take a
piss next to Chris bliss macking on my
sis I had the Irishman that's a great
Cobb man if you didn't catch on theaters
um I was telling you just the other day
about the finale of a more a really
important part of the movie there's a
basically this big there's this really
important sequence in the film that's
like it's about like 25 minutes long in
total and in the theaters it was one of
the most tense movie experiences I ever
had so thank you for bringing up the
Irishman there and aneisa back out of
here what is she saying
wrapping your gifts for your pajama read
it we're wrapping your gifts for your
package at this moment something about
on Monday John you are going to love
your gift same with you Greg also some
other gifts for a special person in your
life
oh the cats are getting gives an ISA
giving the cat's gifts or or Olivia gift
I'm just joking that's smart
hmm smart all especially from the female
subscribers
also jumped I sent you a birthday
message yesterday don't think you've
seen it yet but it's okay I can wait
oh I'm sorry I have a lot of messages to
open up yesterday was not you know
structured out the way we had planned
originally but yeah
much appreciated I will hop on that
after the chat also Greg I love you and
John I look nice so you know how much we
love it out of you we both love you
seriously III have I am one of my I have
fantasies about two things you with us a
couple of trips I really want to take
one is to Atlanta and one is to Texas
and I Oh whenever I think about them
like thinking and hitting up Aneesa in
Texas and then hitting up Eric horseman
in Atlanta because you guys have been
[ __ ] incredible to both of us and so
yeah would absolutely love that
and then another fantasy trip visiting
Erika Tuesday in Burbank and then going
to Britain to meet Ryan P Ellen in
tenant or or or tell in it yeah no all
right yeah I know that's great Tello
trying to bring the allen thing back I
was like what are you doing telling it
love for nice what Ellen
dude that we got to bring the Ellen
thing back which movie that I hate so
much I really did not like the remake of
Nightmare on Elm Street
I kind of hate that movie there's
another movie I remember we both didn't
like identity thief at all but that's
like I feel like there's a movie that I
could like really level hate at but I'd
have to was it sorry to bother you that
you hated you hate it sorry to bother
you
the hate you give 12 years a slave in my
yeah you hated a lot of green books
great green book was on the help
underrated
go to Atlanta let's go to Texas Thank
You Aneesa I can't wait to see what you
got for us and then when we go to Texas
I got a gift for you and your mom it's a
special Polaroid you're gonna like it
you're gonna like it I don't want to get
in a male cos he gets lost I'm gonna
deliver to you in person
as a matter of fact I'm gonna take the
Polaroid for you while I'm in the
bathroom when I'm at your house
boogie you're gonna like it mm-hmm you
know like the way you're gonna you're
gonna like it you're gonna you're gonna
your eyes are gonna light up I don't
know if it's gonna be good or bad
they're gonna light up he Kartik Sharma
Mad Max fury road was blown away with
the car action oh yeah
dust storm sequence added with Symphony
Orchestra soundtrack and adding on to
that Captain America winter soldier a
soldier soldier eligible I'm the winner
soldier I'm the [ __ ] bomb the Indian
audience found up to four Easter egg
references to India oh that's really
core didn't know about that cool and
that's why Joe Russo worked on
extraction yeah Winter Soldier was I saw
we saw that in IMAX together that was
another great movie experience
yeah when her soldiers really stood the
test of time
those few years solid six years 24 2014
when I came out yeah six years right
there thanks for that yeah and oh oh
another one no Kartik Sharma John read
it off also Captain America Winter
Soldier cuz it started Steve's love for
elevators they used to play music it can
lift Thor's hammer figures out Hydra
figures out now outsmarts Hydra Kartik
you sound like you're very much in love
with this Captain America fella
I mean is America's ass it is America's
ass and America's you know is there like
a gay porno of like must be like two of
like two guys who look like me or there
has to be at least one gay porn gay
porno of life a guy
looks like Captain America like like
Chris Evans Captain America [ __ ]
another guy looks like Captain America
and her like yeah [ __ ] America's ass I
exist
I'm literally doing a test to see how
many concurrent viewers are going down
as I'm saying that we've reached went
from 104 to 98 I wouldn't put it I mean
like I don't know if that porn exists
but in a posting world I'm sure it's
yeah plus I mean just the prospect I
mean there have to be so many slash fix
especially with the time travel
possibilities that these universes you
know you could probably have characters
having sex with 3 or 4 versions of
themselves couldn't they do pornos now
were they like deep fake celebrities
faces on to the porn stars yeah yeah I'm
honestly surprised that there's not more
like rampant deep fake [ __ ] yes and
I'm waiting for the day that that
becomes a true problem well I guess
we're wrapping up soon Brendan V day
before seeing great comment
I saw the revival of cats and the guy
who played rum tum tugger took a pic
with an intermission was also the first
time I went to the stage door after a
show damn dude Dana right there you took
a pic with the rum tum tugger that's not
bad I feel like my gay scripts have can
become very divisive in this chat some
people really like it some don't loving
these porn script ideas I've always
wanted to do some kind of segment where
we take like supernatural / fix around
some of those like win cest stories and
do like read them out you know read the
highlights of them or or try to read
them in a way that won't get us demise
but Brendan Vee dude you're making me
want to go see and something in the
actual theaters man an actual like stage
play theater so thank you for that
brandori's of work Brendan thank you for
taking the chance on this stream to
remind us that the theaters are not just
cinemas it's also live performers I can
take a good nap there nice
I feel like it was called like a play as
a poem or something like that I saw a
play that eats Ethan Coen like one of
the Coen brothers like directed and
co-wrote recently that was pretty sweet
also shouts out to Hakeem Johnson I'm
very glad that we are helping to make
that Blount fun yeah that is a high and
then let's see here and okay let's
finish off these John take this away
what do you see what John does just will
close that eyeball there but don't don't
worry so we're gonna get I saw that
comment oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah it's at
a very far distance on this like way
over here
let's try try to be fair to everyone is
having any more worry don't worry
yes Ellen will play Captain America and
the x-rated version know what okay I
call I got a couple things here all
right all right so scourge a 1999 first
movie you saw on a date I went on a
double date to watch the tuxedo love
Jackie Chan but that movie was lame we
saw that together at a screen and I'm
one of those three test screenings yeah
the dear Pierre dear peed in the water
at the beginning I was like this is the
this is the Jackie Chan movie I've been
waiting before I don't I don't remember
us have been like 13 or 14 I think it
was The Grudge goodness gracious - uh
coward is her name Haley she's married
now as a kid and everything god I
remember my I'm reading my first movie
date and I remember all the physical
parts of like being really nervous to
hold hands or whatever and I can't for
the life of me remember what the movie
was I didn't know how to hold her hand
so I punched her mm-hmm yeah it's a
logical and then she became a girl that
must have been it I think yeah I think
it was I think it was a grudge what a
weird first I mean I guess when you're
young that's the right one to watch it
but when you're older you're like let's
watch some intelligent [ __ ] something
romantic when you're young you want it's
a great excuse to cuddle up
everything right so you are brave and
you can curl up in my heart right Todd
like 12 you're just lay those are just
you in trouble
no I like I mean I like it's a weird to
go on a parade of it no I love Marvel
pays me saying in stream Labs here
my favorite theater experience is
watching the MCU in 4k on Disney Plus in
my Fiat whoa you have a theater room god
that's like the Mari must pay you jeez
are you a director just Marvel pay you
to direct I heard you can get like a
mini IMAX the home theater now like you
can seek and set it up where you can get
like an IMAX projected quality oh it's
the [ __ ] sign of course gang at the
size where you can get like the quality
projection of it and the sound of an
IMAX and like a home theater setup okay
that would be cool but damn I'm envious
of that Marvel pays me very very envious
of that
my favorite experience is my [ __ ] and
experience at home with a setup I got I
guess I can't complain if you have your
own that's a great [ __ ] good for you
ma'am Bernice panders Bernie Sanders
Bernie Bernie Sanders with the Bernie
Sanders and amber [ __ ] Ollivanders
since the $10 a cave you guys won't pay
my bill if I don't have the other 150 of
it so it was worth it to make my day
here in you guys acknowledge me of
course your knowledge you Manny's love
the [ __ ] out of you Bernice Thank You
Bernice panders you be wise don't don't
overspend on certain things especially
here I appreciate your generosity
Jed appreciate it dude Derrick horseman
is also saying thank you for - don't
need to contribute anymore Eric alright
Greg did you get the package yet [ __ ]
reg tracking says it was delivered a
local courier of 524 love you guys know
I haven't got
package delivered to the local courier
maybe look maybe the package is so great
I eat that big courier just kept it and
said [ __ ] you and they can probably
get away with [ __ ] like that yeah
exactly
no I haven't got any yet Eric myself
again sent it again yes on the heels yet
another one of what you got and then
send it again yeah man what gives I'm
sorry do haven't gotten it yet man we
should look into that if there's a way
to look into that
alright guys are gonna wrap this up very
shortly but great theatre experiences
have been aired out let's read the last
of these super chats here and then as
you pull that up John John John you know
yes you did click here for the clicking
nisa yes then we can all go visit the
Texas Chainsaw Massacre house together
which I would love isn't that like a
functioning barbecue now also look at my
regular chat for the type of movie
theater I had a question okay let's go
dive into that Austin as well that would
be awesome
oh that sounds great thanks I would love
to be the next Wolverine also creative
gaming thank you I appreciate ya and he
said we would love for you to give us a
tour of Austin I'm dying to go to Austin
especially what's double toasted wants
us to hang out with that they're in the
same room I'm sorry if you're not
getting the attention you want but it's
double toast
alright networking Ellen does not own
own pornhub and Ellen did though wow it
would probably be a more you know
functional like yeah and he said I've
typed in your name here so many times I
can I cannot find a thing every single
king of second island yet no we have not
watched that got a screener for it I
want to watch Artemis Fowl because I
hear it's so awful and I want to see
defy Bloods cuz I heard that's out now
yeah now I'm not I'm not signing there's
information floating out in the ether
and yeah visit the Texas Chainsaw I wait
you you know where the Texas Chainsaw
House's heart it was like for the the
barbecue or something was like for sale
I would I gotta go there are the couches
there that Edie wasn't there the actual
guides based off of no Ed Gein yeah
there's the couches the Ed Gein made at
people's skin is that so on this place
our historical alright they gotta be
there's Oracle [ __ ] down there's gonna
be a whole section did not eat a cake
for breakfast but I hope you did let me
see if she's around to end now that'd be
a great way to end off the stream yeah
Lucy if Olivia's around John yes it's
your birthday answer answer some random
questions or I'll just I'll just share
some some disparate movie theater
experience you know what man I've had
some really cool movie theater
experiences at I got to see the whole
bloody affair cut of Kill Bill in fact
we met Tarantino and Rodriguez at a
screening of grindhouse and machete once
which was very cool I'll never also
forget hardcore Henry the M&M
impressions I'm glad that you liked them
Ellen is palps mother yes I agree 150
likes and Ellen does join the stream or
seven away Olivia how are you Ryan
Beatty gave us a super chest can we get
Riley BIA in the stream guys all right
now show me your tits be a good
girlfriend with all my faculty Jesus
Christ
yeah I don't see it Aneesa don't Dern it
and oh bring up this soup look we look
good John figure look at this crazy
system John's got figured out and then
the last super chat of the day
where's say and it says it's from a nice
and it says yes there there I put the
comment in the regular chat what
comment is it a nice comment Aneesa a
nice you're [ __ ] liar don't don't
don't toy with our emotions this way
especially after the yes and experienced
our just doing more M&M impersonations
until I can find it looking for a
comment like a comet gonna vomit Olivia
and Bolivia on it Donna Rio fair eatin
an eclair doing a staring contest
why granted we're not gonna have
infinite Aneesa I'm sorry I failed you I
put in the regular chat right now I'm
looking at the regular okay hold on
let's see let's go down let's go down
the pop-up lingo you can go home you can
go home dude let's see there are people
sharing their edible regimens Aneesa I'm
so sorry I don't know why it's not
showing up between these super I'll
leave you in charge for five seconds and
it just feels like screenings super chat
and you see I'm not the only one who
doesn't see this is a big situation and
it's got a we got a you know figure it
out there is a gift coming for a live
coming for Olivia see our order license
we put in the chat Olivia there is a
gift coming for you
Olivia there's a gift coming for you
from Anissa there's they said there's a
gift coming for you from Anissa this is
what the normal she says thank you she
says thank you I got you a gift
that from that Japanese show what's
called NART narts NART NART Nardo Nardo
Nardo Mordo no rude oh that's what it is
that was Nardo Nardo if you say it
really I'm a big anime fan looking my
dear you know fullmetal welcoming hero
academia oh we got even more now okay
okay here it is I think this is the last
two we're gonna do the whole experience
you all have talked about it before but
I don't remember what it's called for DX
is that what you're thinking for DX
that's what it is Aneesa or there's also
screen X which is not the same type of
experience but it is like a whole wrap
around which is I think by a similar
company but yeah 40 X they got the rain
the water the smoke there's also I think
XD cinema or something like that does a
similar thing or five denied oh no not
them though 40 X 40 X is the one a stick
where DX real D and screen X is cool and
all but I prefer 40 X 40 X's I want to
continue the soprano at night because
honestly here's how my week has been
okay it's been YouTube's filming editing
patreon filming editing and then I was
on a reality show from Wednesday to
Wednesday I thought I was only going to
be Wednesday to Saturday last week and I
took up a lot of time and then doing
studying for Schmo down and had the
match yesterday then got food poisoning
and got a couple hours of sleep and now
I'm here with you guys so we did I want
to continue The Sopranos tonight weed
that's the plan we didn't ask Olivia if
she's seen sergeant York oh yeah could
we not do damage on all right well I'll
continue these super chats because I am
a huge arrowverse fan especially the guy
who plays captain stretch or whatever
like you get the joke I'm trying to make
greg's and arrowverse fan I have seen
scattered moments and now I'm mostly
aware of the controversy are you an
error verse fan she saw sergeant York
yes
we figured it out what are the last
couple here but yeah Anissa 40x that's
the one we'll take you to it sometimes
Scott Edwards are y'all arrowverse fans
seen all abarim seen all of arrow I've
seen the first five seasons at the flash
4 season and a half of DC's legends of
tomorrow not a bat woman I always watch
the events so I say technically I'm an
arrow verse fan nah I'm not as into it
as I as I was for a while
honestly there's something about arrow
that was just arrow was my jam like the
LOB I feel like flash is the most
beloved
I feel like flash is the most popular
DC's legends of tomorrow the most
recognizes like that's the most quality
and then arrow would fluctuate for a lot
of people era was always my main jam
shots up to Kyle's stain I did not eat
meat Eric horseman I eat meat that was I
got to impossible whoppers is what I got
yeah and and fries and like a small
onion rings cuz I was like it's been a
crazy week I'm in Apatow and I usually
usually when I'm like I have a meal of
like [ __ ] I'm gonna go all out it's
usually way more I think was just a
stress I think it was a combination the
combination of like over loading my
plate too much and then it was like
finally having a second to like oh I can
finally chill out I think I think it may
have been one of those moments to where
your body goes here's an opportunity
where I can send the message loud and
clear that we need to rest and yes Ellen
does replace Hartley sawyers Ellen gated
man five more likes guys we got this and
then multiple gifts well Nisa
thank you no need to you even one gift
after all these super chats and pledges
is is way more than X you've been done
more than enough and he's not Michael in
terms and your very course men seem to
you and Olivia does rock I really feel
like he plays guitar I really feel like
Olivia and Eric will get along
exceptional yeah I think they would we
should talk sometime on the phone Eric
we really should yeah Olivia and Eric
would make great roommates
and aneisa saying yeah we don't have it
in Texas I wish we had a here and there
are multiple you account for Olivia okay
guys my last one love you all
well thank you and Nisa you've been a
[ __ ] incredible this whole time thank
you touch with 4dx and get a theater
area for you you've been incredible too
alright last quick speed all right guys
we are no longer accepting any more
super chats or stream that day so I
appreciate everyone who's been here but
I want to go through go through this
chat really quick how do you get rid of
this John get rid of it
let's let's get oh we got to 150 likes
for John we got so many likes thank you
guys been incredible thank you
really do you appreciate everyone who's
been here for the entire time I know a
lot of you guys have been appreciated
wasn't hopping in and out of here thank
you guys for helping us get to 150 likes
and celebration a homeboys birthday and
thank you everyone who contributed in
this super chat and the stream labs as
well I am excited to take some tums this
is a lot of fun you know supply the most
relaxed we've been every time that high
energy by feds is the most relaxed we've
been and it is nice to have like just a
great conversation throughout with
everyone here today this has been a
great time thank you for the hundred
fifty likes as well so Jonathan last
words to say guys stay beautiful express
yourselves pay attention to what's going
on in the world but also pay attention
to what's going on in your inner world
too because those things need to
harmonize and it's harder than ever to
make that happen so I don't know thank
you all for being here I seriously like
for all the birthday wishes thank you
and I hope you all have a nice relaxing
into your weekend and we'll all be back
at it on Monday to fight the world and
we got a reaction to a BTS video going
up tomorrow night and then reaction to
the oh my god
brain-dead para gram para para pragmatic
pragma prata frag Maura and Resident
Evil going up tomorrow so keep a lookout
for that and thank you again for
everyone who's been here happy birthday
to this guy
much love thank you get back in the
swing of things on Monday we'll see you
guys soon this is this is really this is
really rewarding thank you this is a
great way to end the week seriously
thank you guys thank you
much love